We reached 700,000 subscribers on youtube
yesterday, as many of you know, but as many
of you don't know, this program is on Youtube.
There's an audio podcast.
We're on nearly 200 radio and television stations
syndicated.
We're on a free speech TV, which is a satellite
television channel that airs on Directv and
on dish network.
Youtube has been an, uh, an important platform
for us for many years.
We now have achieved 700,000 subscribers and
this is a huge and absolutely awesome accomplishment.
Thanks to you.
It unfortunately is happening at maybe the
worst time ever, but I'll, I'll explain that
in a moment.
Um, I was looking back at some really interesting
numbers and in our first month on Youtube
we had 30 subscribers.
Okay.
After a full month on Youtube, we had 30 subscribers.
I pulled some data.
It took US 32 months to get to 10,000 subscribers,
32 almost three years to get to 10,000 subscribers
to get from 10,000 to a hundred thousand.
It took us only 30 months to get from 100
to 200,000.
It took us only 17 months to get from 200
to 300,000 it took us 11 months.
I think you see the trend to get from 300
to 400,000 subscribers.
It took us eight months from 400 to 500,000
it took us 10 months.
Things slow down, but then to go from 500
to 600 it took us seven months and we got
from 600,000 to 700,000 subscribers in only
four months.
Where would we be today if hundreds of people
were not unsubscribed by some kind of glitch
in the youtube system from our channel, I
continue to get dozens of emails every single
week from people who say, David, I've been
subscribed for years.
I wasn't seeing your videos.
I went to your channel homepage.
I wasn't subscribed, so I resubscribed.
So that gets to why I said this is an awesome
accomplishment, but not at a very good time.
We are growing the number of subscribers on
the youtube channel very quickly at a time
when youtube is deprioritizing independent
news and politics, content in favor of corporate
legacy media channels.
Not Good.
Youtube is increasingly demonetizing our videos.
Even when people watch them.
Very often the videos don't have ads playing,
meaning that we lose the revenue on those
videos.
A new one that I haven't even opened the door
about is that youtube is now branding a lot
of our content and other news in politics,
content as adult or sensitive, where you have
to confirm that you actually want to see the
clip, which simply reduces the number of people
who watch stuff.
Any barrier you put in place between a person
and a piece of content, no matter how trivial
it appears to be, reduces the number of people
that watch it.
So again, if you're not subscribed, if you
are watching on youtube right now and you
scroll down and the subscribe button is enabled,
press the subscribe button, okay?
Support us directly if you can with 700,000
subscribers.
Imagine if 2% signed up for membership or
Patrion.
This is the best way to support programs you
like.
Go to www.joinpacman.com pick up a membership,
okay?
If 2% of you do that, we are winning bigly.
You can use the coupon code half 19 to drop
your membership costs by 50% and or a throw
us a dollar a month on Patrion, go to patrion.com/david
Pakman show a $1 a month is great.
$2 a month is fantastic.
Imagine if just two or 3% of our audience
gave us a dollar a month on Patrion.
Wouldn't that be a great thing?
So the big picture message, the youtube channel
is growing bigly when it comes to subscribers.
We are doing our best to deal with all of
the other challenges happening, but thanks
to everybody.
I mean it's been, it's been years and uh,
now I, I really do think the next big goal
is a million at this point.
Yes, we'll talk about 800,000 we will talk
about 900,000 but a million is the goal.
Don't know when it'll happen, but you can
get us one closer by subscribing on youtube,
it costs nothing.
Click that subscribe button.